Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
1880:
la lampadina elettrica
a filo incandescente.
1928:
Il motore dell'Harley Davidson.
1973:
la tuta delle missioni Apollo,
quelle che hanno portato
l'uomo sulla Luna.
1986:
il primo computer ad uso domestico.
2018:
la tastiera touch screen.
Alcune delle invenzioni brevettate
che più hanno avuto successo nella Storia;
e ognuna di queste invenzioni
ha, naturalmente, il suo inventore:
Thomas Edison, William Harley, Steve Jobs.
Non tutti sono anche proprietari
dei loro brevetti: pensiamo ad Apple.
Ma dalla qualifica di inventore
derivano diritti patrimoniali e morali.
Capite, quindi, che la parola "invenzione"
è sinonimo di futuro,
di progresso, di creatività.
Ma è una parola
che ha una specifica rilevanza
anche nella sfera del diritto.
Ecco perché vi parlo di invenzioni,
anche se io l'innovazione non la genero:
suggerisco come tutelare le invenzioni,
come sfruttarle economicamente;
talvolta le difendo
nelle aule dei Tribunali,
quando altri se ne
appropriano indebitamente.
Che cos'è un'invenzione,
secondo il diritto?
"La soluzione tecnica
di un problema tecnico".
Deve essere nuova,
e dotata di "altezza inventiva",
non deve cioè essere ovvia, o banale,
per l'esperto di settore,
colui che conosce tutto
dello stato della tecnica.
Se ha queste caratteristiche,
un'invenzione può essere brevettata:
i documenti che avete visto poco fa,
che conferiscono all'inventore
un diritto esclusivo
di sfruttare quell'invenzione
per un massimo di 20 anni.
Ma ad un patto:
che egli descriva quell'invenzione
in maniera tanto dettagliata
da permettere a chiunque di replicarla
allo scadere del brevetto;
e nel frattempo, tutti possono studiarla.
Per superarla, per andare oltre,
verso il progresso della società.
Ecco il patto tra Stato e inventore:
un diritto esclusivo, a fronte
della divulgazione dell'invenzione.
Quanti di voi sanno
che tutti i brevetti della storia
sono liberamente accessibili a chiunque?
Un sapere lì, pronto
per essere studiato e superato.
Ecco chi è allora l'inventore:
colui che crea un ponte
tra ciò che esiste, e può essere studiato,
e ciò che ancora deve essere inventato.
È così che Thomas Edison ci ha traghettato
dall'illuminazione a gas
all'illuminazione elettrica;
che Steve Jobs ha eliminato
la tastiera dai nostri cellulari.
Ma oggi l'uomo, l'inventore,
non è più l'unico che ha accesso
a quel patrimonio di conoscenze.
Oggi ha un concorrente:
l'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Una tecnologia che, tra le altre cose,
è capace di apprendere
da un set di dati e di conoscenze
e a partire da quel set
di dati e conoscenze crea:
immagini; testi; video;
perfino soluzioni tecniche.
Ma chi è, allora, l'inventore?
Nell'attuale sistema tecnologico,
nemmeno chi programma
l'Intelligenza Artificiale
è in grado di prevedere fino in fondo
quale risultato riporterà
questa macchina creativa.
I pensatori del nostro tempo
ci mettono in guardia
rispetto a questa situazione
in cui l'uomo perde la capacità
di anticipare gli effetti del suo agire.
Si perde il senso della Storia:
il passato si traduce nel superato;
e il futuro, semplicemente,
nel perfezionamento di un risultato.
Secondo un equilibrio economico
tra le risorse a disposizione
e gli obiettivi da raggiungere.
Ma come si pone il giurista,
in questo contesto?
Quelle che vedete alle mie spalle
sono due invenzioni:
un contenitore con il bordo frastagliato
e una lampada a LED lampeggiante
per segnalare le emergenze.
Entrambe queste invenzioni
sono state oggetto di un brevetto.
E sapete chi è indicato, quale inventore?
DABUS, un'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Ma l'ufficio statunitense,
e anche quello italiano,
hanno rifiutato di riconoscere
la qualifica di inventore
a un'Intelligenza Artificiale,
sul presupposto che il nostro
attuale sistema legislativo
qualifica come inventore
soltanto una persona fisica.
E per la verità, l'ufficio statunitense
già si era occupato di questa questione
rifiutando di riconoscere
i diritti d'autore
a Naruto, un macaco
che si era fatto un selfie
utilizzato, poi,
da alcune riviste di settore.
Ma si sa, il diritto arriva sempre
in ritardo rispetto alla realtà,
e basta una semplice maggioranza
per cambiare le cose:
nel 2017, in Arabia Saudita,
Sophie è stata riconosciuta cittadina.
È quindi necessario trovare
una giustificazione più convincente
per non riconoscere come inventore
un'Intelligenza Artificiale.
E forse,
la definizione di invenzione
secondo il diritto può essere d'aiuto:
"La soluzione tecnica
ad un problema tecnico".
E attenzione:
il diritto riconosce l'invenzione
anche se l'inventore
non ha fatto alcuno sforzo,
anche se l'invenzione è stata frutto
del caso, di un colpo di fortuna,
purché l'uomo sia in grado di cogliere
la portata non banale di quella soluzione,
nell'ottica di risolvere
il problema tecnico.
Le invenzioni create con l'ausilio
dell'Intelligenza Artificiale,
effettivamente sono proprio questo:
una soluzione trovata per caso,
per un colpo di fortuna.
Ma è ancora l'inventore
che si pone il problema tecnico,
che sceglie che cosa far studiare
a questa Intelligenza Artificiale,
che seleziona, tra i risultati proposti,
quello che meglio risolve il suo problema.
È l'inventore che si pone il problema
e la risoluzione di quel problema
è il suo scopo.
Finché la macchina non farà
questo passo ulteriore,
il processo inventivo è ancora
sotto la responsabilità dell'uomo.
È giusto, quindi, che il diritto valorizzi
questa capacità dell'inventore
di porsi un problema tecnico,
di cogliere la portata non banale
di una soluzione trovata magari per caso.
In questa prospettiva, il progresso
resta appannaggio dell'uomo.
E la tecnologia è uno strumento
al suo servizio,
proprio come lo era il fuoco di Prometeo.
Non a caso, "Pro - metus":
colui che riflette prima,
colui che vede in anticipo.
Credo sia, allora,
proprio questa capacità dell'uomo
di porsi uno scopo, di porsi un problema,
a distinguerlo dalla macchina.
È ciò che rende l'inventore
un ponte verso il futuro.
(Applausi)